today we're reviewing the amd rx 6800 xt
video card this is positioned directly
against nvidia's rtx 3080. it's priced
about 50 below it and it's the
head-to-head competitor in this review
we'll be looking at the rasterization
performance for standard gaming rt
performance we'll be going through smart
access memory and acoustics thermals
frequency validation rpm versus
frequency and thermal validation all
that stuff and plenty more before that
this video is brought to you by crucial
ballistix memory including the new kits
targeted for use with amd's new ryzen
5000 cpus crucial's new ballistics max
memory is some of the highest performing
memory on the market and can be tuned
for timings and clocks to improve
performance the company also has its
other crucial ballistics kits for a more
affordable entry to enthusiast grade
memory crucial is a micron brand and has
direct access to its own memory supply
learn more at the link in the
description below so for this thing it's
this one in particular is about 50 under
the 38 supposed to be 650 bucks the
reference cards are launching first from
amd directly partner models will sort of
trickle out slowly over the following
couple two to three weeks from what
we're told right now you might see some
popping up within the first week or so
but that's about the delay for the
partner models and for our content we
have already a pretty in-depth thermal
follow-up so we'll do a whole bunch of
ways you can kind of upgrade the
reference cooler because it's not great
really so we have follow-up content for
that we've also got some content for
water cooling for more extreme
overclocking but we've done overclocking
in this review as well as far as the
specs well we're going to point you
towards our video for the launch but
we'll also pop up a spec sheet on the
screen briefly so this review is crammed
with information we don't want to read
through just the spec sheet for it
we have a tear down coming up same day
we have an rx 6800 non-xt review coming
up same day as well it will be within
easily within 24 hours of this review
going live
and a follow-up testing shortly
thereafter including a live stream
sometime in the next day or so the test
matrix has ballooned like crazy because
of smart access memory so we've cut some
stuff we normally have in reviews to
replace it with smart access memory
testing the
basics of it is that if you have a ryzen
5000 cpu a 500 series motherboard like
x570 and then an rx6000 series gpu you
can get the the cpu can more directly
address the gpu memory and improve
performance in some cases this is done
with some driver level stuff some s bios
level stuff and nvidia is working on its
own pcie resizable bar for the future
but it doesn't have it today so for
today we're doing sam testing with amd
on versus off versus nvidia on an amd
platform and then we also have our
standard test platform on intel which
once you have those higher resolutions
they're all the cps are going to be same
anyway once you're looking at 4k so a
lot to go through let's get into the
testing numbers we need to start out by
validating the frequency range to ensure
the device is operating as expected
please note that this chart is
intentionally zoomed to a tight range of
250 megahertz in order to better see the
behavior but it does make the changes
look more blown out we're assuming the
reported frequency is the clock domain
for the gpu but we have a suspicion that
it might be something else either way
though all that matters is that we're
measuring the same frequency for all of
these tests and we discourage comparing
frequency to frequency between devices
just like in cpus there's a lot more to
it than just the frequency number the
6800 xt stock frequency in our standard
repeat frame render benchmark plots at
2340 to 2355 megahertz after an extended
test period but the initial frequency
spiked at launch is 2450 megahertz and
then 23.75 megahertz and then a rapid
decay as the temperature rises this is
expected behavior of all gpus currently
in the gaming card market including
nvidia's enabling rage mode doesn't
appear to do much of anything the
frequency increases by maybe 10 to 20
megahertz but that line doesn't flatten
in any meaningful way and that's really
what we'd want to see this aligns with
what amd told us to expect of rage mode
though which was maybe a one to two
percent increase remember rage mode just
lifts the power budget slightly it
doesn't even max it out and it increases
the aggression of the fan curve so it's
not technically overclocking anything
it's just affording more power budget
for native clock boosting behavior this
next chart shows the thermal pwm
response of fans for each mode tested
fully stock the auto rpm and a repeat
render gaming workload is about 16 30
rpm with occasional 10 rpm dips so those
don't matter enabling rage mode does
boost the fan curve as amd said settling
now at 1760 rpm we'll go over what that
means for noise in a moment but the
impact of thermals is a change of about
3 degrees celsius for t-junction hotspot
temperature which is noteworthy when
considering the rpm increase the average
gpu temperature also sees about a 4
degree swing except rage mode is running
lower than stock as a result of its fan
rpm increase overall
this mode does run hotter for the
hotspot and a higher rpm for a minor
frequency increase we normally do
pressure map testing to illustrate how
the cooler secures against the gpu which
is helpful in determining the thermal
performance and the contact patch we
also typically show cold plate flatness
to show the point-to-point depth in
microns for this one though we're going
to skip past those for a follow-up piece
instead we're halfway through additional
thermal tests on how to improve the
overall mediocre and the reference
solution so you'll see the pressure and
flatness data there that's also where
we'll show the 40 dba noise normalized
thermals but this one with the addition
of sam and rt testing it was just too
much here's a quick map of the acoustic
response for the 6800 xt and the 6800
for that matter the auto fan speeds had
it in the range of 41 dba already on
this curve but the curve is fairly
predictable and terminates at 57.4 dba
pretty standard for coolers as always
this high number will only happen if you
manually adjust to 100 fan speed so you
don't need to worry about it but it does
give you some extra cooling push if
needed we couldn't measure below 900 rpm
due to the limitations of our 26 db
noise floor but overall for the auto
speeds in our test environment lands
around the 40 to 41 mark before we get
into the standard game suite with all of
the gpus on the charts including about a
dozen or so other ones we want to start
with validating sam or smart access
memory we started with just a subset of
games for some quick a b testing here
these were selected randomly from our
existing test suite except for hitman 2
at 4k ultra which we chose specifically
because amd claimed an unusually high 10
performance increase from enabling sam
our standard ryzen cpu test bench was
used for these tests along with a
gigabyte x570 master with 3200 megahertz
14 14 14 memory and an amd r9 5900x
locked at 4.7 gigahertz all core sam
testing gets off to a promising start
with shadow of the tomb raider at 1080p
where the 6800xt was initially tied with
the msrp
priced rtx 3080 eagle enabling sam
resulted in only a 3.5 percent uplift
versus stock at 213 fps versus 206 fps
average with the lows unchanged that's
still enough for it to pull ahead of the
nvidia card and now three percent ahead
of the 3080s 207 fps average given that
this is an amd platform it also means
that we have more headroom and cpu bound
1080p scenarios than intel often offers
although many of our gpu test settings
do ensure a bind even at the lower
resolutions but it's not always the case
that amd won't end up cpu bound moving
to 4k shows the same order of results
albeit with a much reduced average frame
rate the 3080 is 1.7 ahead of the 6800xt
without sam at 92 fps versus 94 average
but enabling sam flips that order and
puts the 6800 xt 1.8 percent ahead
instead these aren't noticeable
differences in game but it is enough to
give amd a competitive edge in some
instances and certainly enough to change
the order in the charts as with all
these tests except hitman 2 red dead
redemption 2 was chosen without any
knowledge of predicted performance and
these testing suggests some small
performance scaling may be possible in
red dead at least when using vulcan but
we happened to choose dx12 in this
instance and saw no significant change
in performance at 1080p that said we
also have vulcan tested later on in the
test suite the 6800xt was already 2.1
percent ahead of the rtx 3080 in this
benchmark and the average with sam
enabled was 2.4 percent ahead an
improvement of less than one fps average
well within variance and run to run
deviation there is no change in this
title and this api further still amd's
lead is a result of running against the
cpu limitation in this particular title
and so is artificial in that both gpus
are bouncing off of the frame rate limit
moving to 4k instead reveals the cpu
bottleneck we hit at 1080p with the rtx
3080 now 13 ahead of the 6800 xt that
doesn't change the results from enabling
sam though which is what we're testing
mostly in this section there was still
no significant change actually basically
no change at all to aim these results
with or without it we've repeated the
other game tests for this section to
1080p and 4k only but selected the three
kingdoms battle benchmark as the one
game for sam testing where we run 1440p
as well the first pass at 1080p had the
rtx 3080 2.8 ahead of the 6800 xt but
sam reduced that gap to 1.2 percent at
1440p the performance gap between nvidia
and amd grew with the 30 85 and a half
percent ahead of the stock 6800 xt but
then reduced to 5.2 percent ahead with
sam enabled that had them at 90 fps
average for amd and 95 fps average for
nvidia nvidia seems to hold rops and a
bandwidth advantage as well running the
test at 4k plays the 3080 at 50 fps
average 11.9 percent of the 6800 xt the
efficacy of sam dwindled at this
resolution only reducing the 3080s
performance advantage to 11.1 percent
the 3080 did suffer from worse one
percent and 0.1 lows at this resolution
as compared to some others with the 6800
xt's relatively stable 38 fps issue lows
actually technically beating the 30 80s
lows rainbow six siege's behavior was
unusual from the norm but is something
we've seen in our other gpu suite on the
other platform we'll get to those
numbers soon at 1080p the 6800xt had a
respectable 7.8 lead over the 3080 eagle
that's 495 fps average versus 459 fps
average with no change from sam which is
impressively consistent given how high
the average frame rates are we were
suspicious of a potential 500 fps engine
limit given how close these averages are
so we checked the frame times and saw
that there were periods during the test
where it would push past 500 fps it
appears that there is no limit here at
least in our test setup at 4k the
advantage flipped to nvidia by a wide
margin thanks again to its memory
bandwidth and advantages there the rtx
3080 was 20.5 percent ahead of the 6800
xt and still no change with sam enabled
even in the one percent and 0.1 lows
average fps with sam off was 153.91
and average fps with sam on was 153.96
our final test is one we added to
validate the claim that there are some
games with a large performance scaling
with sam we tested only at 4k since
that's where amd's numbers showed the
largest change the original results
resemble tomb raiders for hitman 2 with
the 3080 and 6800 xt tied at just over
100 fps average enabling sam raised the
6800xc's performance above both of those
non-sam tests by 10.6 percent up to 111
fps average with a modest improvement in
the 1 lows as well from 57 to 64. the
takeaway is that sam is hit and miss
this matches with what nvidia told us
about its future implementation the
company is considering implementing a
whitelist or blacklist for certain games
based on whether or not those games
actually benefit from enabling a
resizable pcie bar moving back to our
standard gpu test bench we'll start with
a shadow of the tomb raider at 4k with
the full suite of cards the 6800xt stock
card plotted at about 93 fps average on
this platform which isn't comparable to
our sam tests and platform and therefore
ranked technically ahead of the rtx 3080
fe cart overclocking the fe leapfrogged
it over the 6800xc stocks just barely
and overclocking the 6800xt did the same
thing putting it back in a technical
lead ultimately these two produce
roughly the same experience at 4k which
is more of a statement for amd than it
is for nvidia at this point the 6800xtoc
gains 2.6 percent over the stock 6800xt
so not great in this title compared to
the 1080ti f23 the older pascal card is
led by 84 percent in the scenario and
the 5700 xt is led similarly by the
6800xt as for
rage mode that improves performance by
negative 0.2 fps average it's within run
to run variants and was unhelpful in
doing anything other than running the
fan louder the 1440p results positioned
the 6800xc stock card as 6.5 percent
ahead of the 3080 fe a decisive victory
here with the overclock producing enough
of an upswing to bring it above the 30
90 fe stock results from the original
review the 172 fps average is a 4.7
percent improvement over the stock
6800xt posting a significantly higher
benefit than the 2.6 we saw at 4k but
it's still not amazing for an overclock
compared to the older days of
overclocking gps out of the box rage
mode again did nothing here at 1080p
we're completely cpu bound and cannot
determine a meaningful difference
between any of the top results they're
all bouncing off of the cpu limit and so
this data is about as useful as testing
cpus at 4k it's helpful only in saying
that if you're playing at 1080p with one
of these high-end cards it's the cpu
that matters more unless you're
extremely gpu bound with settings that
aren't available in this title but might
be in say total war rage mode shows
marginal uplift but this is cpu bound
anyway so it's invalid total war 3
kingdoms is up next tested with the
punishing ultra settings at 4k nothing
has cracked 60fps in this test yet
thanks to the somewhat needlessly high
graphics settings we've configured but
that allows us to see the most scaling
going forward here the 6800xt stock car
did 42.5 fps average improving by 6.8
percent with the 6800 xt oc to 45 fps
average the rtx 3080 fe ran at 47 here a
lead of 10.4 percent over the 6800 xt
stock card compared to the 5700 xt is 23
fps average or the 1080 ti is similar
frame rate the 6800 xt is about 84 85
percent ahead the most noticeable thing
happening here is the one percent and
0.1 low has been disproportionately
better for the rx 6000 series cards with
the 30 series cards running fine but
aligned much worse against their average
versus what the 6800 is seen we'll need
a frame time plot for that though here's
a look at the frame time plot lower is
better but more consistent is best the
rx 6800xt stock card plotted within a
range of about three to four
milliseconds which is excellent frame
time consistency overall from one frame
to the next the frame times are overall
higher by nature of this being 4k but
the consistency is good and remember
that frame times in a plot like this are
the best way that we currently have to
show an empirical look at the frame to
frame performance of gameplay nvidia's
consistency at the start of this test is
all over the place it's not experience
ruining a spike two or beyond for
example 100 milliseconds would be but
it's not great either the card is
bouncing around and five to ten
millisecond swings with a few swings
closer to
point to point twelve to fourteen
milliseconds this particular game showed
this behavior in the sam tests on the
amd platform as well which is an
entirely different operating system and
uh technically newer driver for nvidia
so this is present on both platforms at
1440p the 6800xt stock card did 88 fps
average with rage mode again within
variant and about as anti-climactic as
possible for something named rage mode
overclocking improves it to 94.5 fps
average or seven percent which is enough
to roughly equal the rtx 3080 feoc the
3080fe stock card did 93 fps average
which leads the 6800xt stock card by
about 5.3 percent at 1080p we're not
bound by the cpu for this game so we
still see scaling the frame time
consistency improves here leading us to
believe something else screwy is going
on with the pacing at those higher
resolutions for nvidia but amd is still
technically ahead on average for its low
performance the 6800 xt stock did 140
fps average with rage mode providing
zero value whatsoever the 6800xtoc
improved 5.2 percent to 147 fps average
putting it between the 3090 fe stock
card and the 3080 feoc stock to stock
the 3080 fe is technically in the lead
but thus far the card differences in
average fps aren't too meaningful
horizon zero dawn at 4k is next with the
custom settings used tuned to beat up
the gpu more than anything else the rx
6800xc stock gpu and 78 fps average with
raid mode actually improving the score
by a few percentage points in this one
the overclock pushes it to 88 fps
average landing between the 3080 oc at
92 fps average and 3080 fe stock at 87.
the 3080 fe stock holds a lead over the
6800 xt and its enraged counterpart at
1440p the results positioned the 6800xc
stock card at
fps average allowing the 380 fe a lead
of 2
reduced from the lead it held at 4k
that's similar to what we've seen a few
times now the overclocks for each card
equalizes them in this one at 1080p the
6800 xt holds a lead over the 3080 fe of
about two and a half percent so amd
pulls a little bit ahead at the lower
resolutions while nvidia can leverage
its bandwidth to lead at the higher
resolutions the 6800x coc ended up ahead
of the 3090fe stock card as a result of
amd's improved performance at
resolutions closer to 1080. with red
dead redemption 2 we'll look at dx12
versus vulcan scaling first since people
always bicker about which one they think
should be tested even though slightly
different things are being rendered and
therefore the performance is different
amd's rx 6800xt is the first gpu in a
long time that actually runs worse with
vulkan here this is interesting seeing
as vulcan had its roots in amd's own
mantle project while the nvidia rtx 3080
for instance ran seven and a half
percent better than its own results in
vulcan than in dx12 given the other
vulcan limitations of our dna ii so far
which are being addressed like in ray
tracing we wonder what's going on over
at vulcan's previous champion gpu maker
we're going to start reading these
faster for time and we'll focus on the
3080 and 6800 xt if you want more info
on older cards you'll have to pause in
red dead 2 at 4k and dx12 the rx 6800xc
stocked at 75 fps average improving 3
with the oc with rage mode doing nothing
the 3080 fe stock therefore leads the
6800 xt stock by 13
with the 3080 feoc leading the 6800x toc
by 16 and a half percent at 1440p the
rtx 3080 fe leads the 6800 xt by 1.9
percent a significantly reduced lead
from its 4k positioning the 6800 xt's oc
positions it around the 390 fe stock
result and ahead of the 3080f eoc by 6.3
percent at 1080p the 6800xt stock card
now ties with the 39dfe stock card we're
close to cpu limits but the 6800x toc
shows that there's a little bit more
room left in this game the 6800xt stock
outperformed the 380fv stock by 2
percent here flipping the script with
the oc chart topping the 3080 scales
much better at 4k
but the 6800 xt does better at 1080p
we've spent more than enough time on fps
charts and we need to make sure this
review doesn't balloon too much a
pattern has clearly been established at
this point so we're just gonna flash
through several other charts that we've
made now but we won't be talking through
that this is just to cut down the video
time you can pause this section if you'd
like to see any detail on any particular
game the gta 5 1080 results are
interesting but otherwise the only thing
left for game discussion will be ray
tracing performance time to briefly test
ray tracing performance we're giving
this the same level of focus we gave the
30 series at launch so low for rt the
6800 xt does get trounced thoroughly in
these results though with shadow of the
tomb raider at 4k bringing the 6800 xt
down to 48 fps average we have dlss
disabled for this game the rtx 3080 fe
dlss disabled holds an 18 lead at 56 fps
the 6800 xt is a bit ahead of the 2080
ti from last generation and moving to
1440p the 6800 xt ran 86 fps average
allowing the 3080 fe a lead of 14
at 1080p the 3080 fe retains a 15 lead
over the 6800 xt stock card control is
difficult it's completely valid to play
control with the lss since dls2 in this
game is actually good but it's also not
a like for like comparison to account
for this we tested both at sort of 4k
because dlss is on the rtx 3080 did
65fps average which is completely
playable the 6800xt can't enable the lss
so that one is at 23fps average it will
get a feature similar to this at some
point but that's not out yet the 3080 is
therefore 180
faster with dlss enabled with dlss off
for all of the cards the rtx 3080 held
37fps average leading the
xt still by 59 at 1080p the rtx 3080 fe
ran 137 fps average with dlss leading
the 6800 xt by 95
70 fps is still playable but if you're
planning to focus on rt titles or use
optics that nvidia is the better choice
with dlss off the rtx 3080 leads the
6800xt by 51 percent here with minecraft
at 4k the rtx 3080 runs 87 fps average
leading the 6800 xt's 14 fps average by
that is literally the highest
improvement we've ever seen between two
cards we're working on reviewing in one
chart the reason is that dlss works
particularly well in minecraft and it's
a valid use of it since it all looks the
same in this game anyway the non-dlss
3080 did 33 fps average falling to only
a 140 advantage over the 68 xt finally
with minecraft at 1080p the 3080 did 163
fps average with dlss on leading the 68
xt by 240
if you think it is somehow invalid to
allow nvidia to use a feature which in
this situation is legitimately good
specifically for minecraft well with it
off the lead diminishes to 92 percent
andy does well in rasterization and it's
extremely competitive there but if you
really care about ray tracing
performance you should probably still be
looking at nvidia assuming you can get
one power consumption testing is up next
for this we're using a pcie cable and
slot interposer so this shows the total
card power consumption not the wall
power consumption we've done it this way
for a few years and this data is
comparable to most of our old test data
through at least 2018. for furmark at 4k
the rx 6800 xt stock card pulled about
294 watts putting it about 25 watts
below the rtx 3080 fe card or about 10
watts higher than the gtx 1080 ti f23
stock cart overclocking the rx 6800 xt
put it at 342w and although not present
on this chart our initial undervolt
testing did not actually improve this
number presumably because the current
increased but we'll talk about that more
in future content the overclocked
results put it alongside the aftermarket
30 series cards particularly the
overclocked ones and about 10 watts
below the rtx 3090 fe stock card in a
gaming scenario with total war at 4k the
rx 6800 xt pulled 289 watts from the
stock or 334 when overclocked not shown
here it was about the same at 1440p the
stock numbers have it adjacent to the
1080ti stock and about 30 watts higher
than the asrock 5700xt tai chi x when it
was stock or about 30 watts below the
3080fe when that one was stuck it's also
approaching 40 watts below the 3080
eagle when the gigabyte card is stuck
the overclocked 6800xt numbers have it
closer to the 3080 tough one in the
stock performance v bios just for
reference to an aftermarket card there
was an amd card a few generations ago
that drew too much pcie slot power so we
decided to check those numbers as well
infer mark at 4k the left pcie cable did
about 130 watts average the right one
did about 132 watts average and the slot
did 32.3 watts for the 12 volt rails or
0.3 watts for the 3.3 volt rails these
numbers add up to about 302 watts which
is higher than the number we reported a
moment ago from fermark but remember
this these are averages across several
hundred cells for each one so the global
average is going to be a little bit
different from secondary averages for
the numbers that comprise the global
because they're measured across
different periods ultimately the pcie
slot is well below spec for 12 volts
which is 66 watts so amd's running about
half of that this table shows our raw
notes for overclocking the 6800 xt the
process wasn't particularly easy andy
still has graceless driver failures when
an overclock fails which means the
screen will turn blue and become
unresponsive requiring a hard reset
after a failed overclock the tuning is
also done with a minimum and maximum
clock slider rather than a pure offset
we find this method to be troublesome to
use and find that it produces no change
sometimes in performance while other
times it produces larger swings that are
pursuant to the frequency numbers you
type it for example in some cases clock
offsets actually do nothing but others
produce the expected results and you can
see all that in this chart you can see
also in row 19 where we increased the
offset range from 2500 to 2600 in the
previous row to 2530 to 2630 and this
one with an observed increase in clock
of 30 megahertz putting us up to 24.85
to 24.90 that's the expected behavior
but not every row was like that and
remember that the number you type in for
the min and max isn't the number that
it's actually running so if you type
2500 to 2600 that doesn't mean it's
running at 2600 megahertz just before
anyone posts their reddit results of
their overclocks in the thermals column
thermals become almost uncontrollable
once overclocked on this card the
trouble is that going beyond 80 to 85
fan speed starts to chew away so much at
the power that the clocks were running
worse at 100 fan speed we did some
undervolting but we were unconvinced
during part of this that it was doing
much as you'll see in line 17 however we
have another chart in a moment for that
it's likely more work can be done with
undervolting and we're already working
on a follow-up piece going back to the
first few rows though we can look at the
thermal impact on frequency at play no
changes were made but after running for
a few minutes the clocks fell from 2290
to 2312 and row 2 to 22 17 to 22 77 in
row 3 after a subsequent increase in
temperature and an auto fan speed
increase we were able to stabilize the
maximum frequency offset of 150
megahertz for the memory with andy
disallowing a further increase through
official means the clock was seemingly
stable at 25 90 to 26 90 for the range
but the actual clock was 25 28 to 25 60
and this is actually an invalid oc which
is another important point before the
reddit post start with the amd
especially but in general with
overclocking you always have to validate
overclocks to ensure there isn't a score
regression let's look at that in a chart
never set your overclock without
checking the score change when you think
it's stable because it's not enough to
just reach and assume stability where
it's not crashing anymore and then run
it the scores can actually tank with a
better oc while still presenting
seemingly high clocks we saw this last
amd launch for gpus where a lot of users
thought they were running way higher
clocks than their scores would reflect
the same happens with rtx when people
run memory that isn't really stable you
will see posts online where people claim
seemingly impossible frequencies but
without score validation it's hard to
say if they're legitimate here you'll
see that our stock run was 85 50 points
and times by extreme with the 25 90 to
26 90 clocks we showed a moment ago
actually reducing the score by a massive
6.2 percent we observed the small uplift
going to 2500 to 2600 instead where we
produced an 8645 score mostly improving
the gt1 from the core the test at 25.50
to 26.50 reduced score again with an
undervolt to provide more power headroom
not really changing much undervolting
appeared to help in the end though if we
highlight the last three rows you'll see
that we ran the same settings three
times but with a voltage change in the
middle we routinely produced a higher
score with the voltage dropped to 1100
we tried 1090 millivolts in the settings
but it crashed we tuned further beyond
this chart for the actual in-game
testing which is why you see a bigger
uplift in the game test than you do here
but it did take a good couple of hours
to really dial in those clocks that we
ran for the game tests that's it for the
review then teardown will be up shortly
again
6800 review non xt will be up shortly
for the basics of this rasterization
performance is very strong at the lower
resolutions like 1080p 1440p to some
extent and then at 4k and the it's hit
and miss where they're either roughly
parity within a couple fps to the point
that it just frankly doesn't matter you
just buy whichever one has an extra
feature that you want or whichever one's
available or cheaper and then
as you get towards certain titles you
might get a 13 uplift and sometimes
closer to 15 depending on the
exact cards you're looking at for 4k on
nvidia where it benefits from bandwidth
and rops
over amd's card but amd has an advantage
in general at 1080p 1440. so if you're
really focused on 1080p high refresh
gaming and you can get a high
performance cpu to go with it like ryzen
5000 right now being the top gaming
performer these days that's still new to
say
then the 6800x he might make the most
sense for that type of scenario whereas
if you want ray tracing performance or
4k performance specifically you probably
should be looking towards nvidia and
especially with ray tracing performance
amd is just not even close right now
it's not even a contest they'll get
there eventually presumably but this is
amd's first foray into ray tracing a
real-time ray tracing and so it's kind
of in that mid between 20 series on 30
series territory and not quite
uh
well really anywhere close to the 3080
right now for the games we've tested
there are a lot more games out there we
do a pretty limited ray tracing test
suite because it's never been a big
focus of hours at least not right now
there's not enough games for us to
heavily focus on that and so if you care
about ray tracing we'd encourage you to
check out additional reviews by other
people where they might have tested more
games just to make sure you get the full
scope of how the card performs but from
what we've tested the three games
dropping quake because it doesn't work
on the rx 6800 xt right now
or and maybe not in the future but
dropping quake the three games we did
test nvidia's got to lead whether or not
dlss is on so
that's something to consider if you're
into rasterization though definitely
look into the 6800xt some more and as
always we'd encourage you to check out
additional reviews from our peers
in case there's some more that you want
to learn about it and check back for our
follow-ups because we have a whole lot
of them coming up including thermal
testing or improvements really to the
cooler and that is the biggest weak
point of this card we'd say probably
wait for a partner model rather than
getting reference but we've been saying
that for years now so that's it for this
one thank you for watching subscribe for
more as always you can go to
store.gamersaccess.net that helps out
directly or
patreon.com we'll see you all next time
[Music]
the